welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is an explanation of the
ending of the season finale of Star Wars
and org and thank you to WB Games for
sponsoring this video more on them in a
moment I'm recording this right as I'm
prepping a lead for my Thanksgiving
holiday so I'm really just going to talk
about the ending of this amazing season
of streaming content and how it was so
cleverly set up throughout the season
there's gonna be a lot that I don't
cover in this video but that's all going
to come out in my full episode breakdown
that I'm gonna take some extra time with
that'll come out on Monday thank you so
much for your patience as always I think
you know by now that I like to dive
deeper into the visuals try to correctly
identify all the Star Wars ship designs
and translate all the orabish it's gonna
be hard for me to do all that while I'm
traveling to be with my family so anyway
the ending of this amazing season and or
was always conceived by Tony Gilroy to
be two seasons 24 episodes total 12
episodes per season and here at this
Midway point we saw the first year of
Cassian andors entry into the Rebellion
when the rebellion was still in its
early stages tightly controlled by
spycraft from people like Lutheran Royal
funded by nervous politicians like Von
mothma and fed philosophically by
Progressive thinkers like nemec but that
final trigger waiting to be pulled by
feuding factions of ex-criminals
runaways and people just looking for a
reason to blow something up but this
season one finale marked the transition
from that first early era to the era of
open guerrilla warfare against the
empire a showdown where we started on
the planet farrix the blue collar town
that murks each passing Day by striking
metal and communicating warnings to each
other similarly a sound that Marvel at
episode 3 described thusly it's two
doesn't it that's what a reckoning
sounds like
you wanted to stop but it just keeps
coming it's when it stops
when you really want to start to fret
now Marvel was shown suddenly dead in
episode 11 and we knew that couldn't be
the last we saw Fiona Shaw in this
series it just couldn't and sure enough
she had some Just Desserts planned for
the Empire remember Marva spent her
dying weeks probing the ferric's hotel
for a tunnel beneath that the rebels
could use to catch the Empire off guard
and when she died like all ferric's
deceased people her body was turned into
a brick to be added to a wall but we saw
her body being moved out of the home
with all these mysterious close-ups of
her Droid b2emo specifically his
eyepiece B was oddly insistent that he
not leave this home and trembled
violently when the daughters of Barracks
discussed moving him and as we watched
Marvis corpse move outside and the
window reflection was Bee's ghostly
translucent form hovering over this
corpse this finale episode inverts that
image with the ghostly pre-recorded
projection of Marvel rallying the locals
from Beyond the Grave there was a
Darkness glitching like rust into
everything to everything around us we
let it grow and now it's here the Empire
is a disease is that thrives in darkness
it is never More Alive than when we
sleep
it's easy for the dead to tell you to
fight and maybe it's true maybe fighting
is useless if I could do it again
I'd wake up early and be fighting
these bastards work
from the start
fight the Empire
oh my God it is so amazing so what we
are seeing is really the death of Luther
rails era of Cloak and Dagger spycraft
that require disguises and meeting in
the shadows where timing is everything
and human beings are treated like pawns
to be sacrificed only at specific
moments away from that calculation and
more to an unwieldy Grassroots Wildfire
of a rebellion a more openly populist
approach where everyone's welcome to
join the fight no one really has to be
recruited anymore they're falling over
themselves to join now to be clear
Lutheran spycraft was certainly
necessary to get the Rebellion to this
point but historically the more truly
successful rebellions at some point must
shift into a new phase of chaotic messy
charging where masses of late adopters
join the movement for a variety of
motives this is truly the one way out
that we saw so effective and so
inspiring in the prison break of episode
10. this is the era Star Wars Rebels is
set in and the era of Rogue one and it's
the kind of thing that we can expect to
see next season which has begun
production already but the post-credits
scene we see in this episode
finally reveals what those prisoners
were assembling in the narkina 5 Prison
those three rm2 six armed nodes that
they just kept racking and racking up
and as you suspected these are pieces of
the Death Star now if there's one thing
I like about the general power fantasy
vibe or the kinds of shows we cover here
it's the power fantasy no twist here
it's just straight up fun to fantasize
about being super powerful it's even
more fun when that fantasy is paired
with you know a controller in your hands
and a franchise you love like Lego Star
Wars Lego Star Wars the Skywalker Saga
Galactic Edition is the most expensive
Lego Star Wars game ever its gameplay
takes you through all nine Skywalker
Saga films and has 13 playable character
packs spanning the Galaxy from Tatooine
all the way back around to Tatooine how
do we keep winding up back there Lego
Star Wars the Skywalker Saga Galactic
Edition includes six new packs and
character collection two which adds 30
new playable characters from Star Wars
TV shows like and or Star Wars the Clone
Wars and Star Wars Rebels that's on top
of seven character packs in the
previously released character collection
so now you can smash and build your way
through a galaxy far far away as whoever
you'd like Lego Star Wars the Skywalker
Saga Galactic Edition is available now
on Xbox series XS Xbox One PlayStation 5
PlayStation 4 Nintendo switch and PC
like in Rogue one there's an excellent
use of scale to shock us with awe of how
big this thing exactly is starting close
with just a few droids buzzing the piece
into place and then zooming out further
and further to show all the pieces of
the focus dish coming together at the
end of episode 10 Lutheran said he was
damned to use the tools of his enemy to
destroy them and the prisoners of arcade
5 use these tools and these exact parts
to fight their way out of their rooms
parts that were literally being used to
build a death star that will be used to
destroy so many lives including the life
of Cassie and Andor himself also in a
haunting Twist of humor you could say
the imagery kind of looks like a how-to
assembly booklet for furniture or
appliances are you screw together in
your living room where you see the screw
in the washer and the bolts all fanned
outward ready to be twisted into place
it's kind of like where Peter Parker net
is simply in a Lego Death Star right now
and for the Empire that's what this is
It's almost like a childlike assembly of
something that they needed yesterday and
aren't really gonna appreciate the real
function of Cassian hinted in episode 10
that these parts weren't just busy work
whatever we're making here is clearly
something they need
can't afford to be surprised again and
back in episode 4 young in the ISB
reported on construction in the abreon
sector elaborate on these added
protection requests for traffic to the
Abram sector proactive measures sir
there's an increase in construction
shipments going to scarif sir yes scarif
is the planet where the Death Star
construction is completed in Rogue one
and we are rapidly approaching that
point now the fact that young oversaw
the embryon sector and scarif and young
secretly reported Lutheran Lutheran who
would presumably share his Intel with at
least CLIA but probably now saw Herrera
there's hope that some early warning of
this battle station's construction could
reach the right sources for the mission
of Rogue one to kick off aha yes I do
hope of course it will work out but
that's what's so great about this show
it crowns you so firmly in the moment to
moment struggles of these characters and
avoids Nostalgia or over the top
dramatic irony of what's gonna happen in
the future and we forget that the future
for the rebellion in the Empire is such
a certain thing in the meantime focusing
on these granular details just gives us
deeper context and appreciation for
everything we saw in the original 1977
Star Wars film which is as it should be
every tower that shoots down the next
Wing or a y-wing built from prison slave
labor by Cassian and Kino and the rest
and when this damn thing blows up the
evil fruits of their labor is finally
going to be cleared off their
consciences and yes practically speaking
even the exhaust Port that Galen erso
designed in the schematics and later
exploited by a young pilot from Tatooine
also built by narkina five Prisoners the
day will come when all these skirmishes
and battles
moments of defiance will have flooded
the banks of banks of the Empire's
Authority Authority and then there will
be one too many one single thing will
break The Siege I love this I'm gonna go
way further into this whole finale
episode in my full episode breakdown
which again is coming Monday thank you
for your patience and for those asking
about our Wikileaks after show we just
paused them for Andor but we will likely
pick back up with them for the
Mandalorian season 3 in 2023 and Ahsoka
Beyond but in the meantime if you want
to see Tommy and me live along with
Jessica Clemens Brandon Barrick and Zach
Huddleston come to the Los Angeles
Comic-Con where new rock stars will be
appearing live on Sunday December 4th
check out the description for more
details and thanks again to WB Games for
sponsoring this video you can follow me
on Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at a
boss follow me rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you